good morning believe nation today's
message is be confident over to you Bill
Ackman the best investments are the ones
where we are the confident we're right
and everyone else is wrong okay and you
have to in order to be you know I've
been accused recently of being arrogant
among the only thing I know I'm gonna
actually ask you that it was called it
was pompous but that's okay
pompous I don't think I'm pompous but if
it certainly been accused of being
arrogant and there's a difference
between arrogance and confidence yeah if
you're arrogant and investing you're
gonna get killed all right if you're not
confident you'll never make an
investment all right so you have to do
in a sufficient amount of work to be
confident enough to have a conviction
do something that's contrarian right we
bought the stock of a a soon to be
bankrupt retailer I'm sorry a shopping
mall company during the financial crisis
at pennies per share you have to be
willing to look silly when you do
something like that general growth
stocks up ninety fold since our original
investment you know on that's we had
confidence maybe we'll flow is arrogant
to believe that we could be successful
in turning around but you also have to
be humble I think entrepreneurs need to
be confident I think most entrepreneurs
are confident but we have we have these
nagging voices in our head that
sometimes tell us you can't do this you
won't be successful you'll never reach
that big goal that you have and I think
you have to have confidence as an
entrepreneur because you're gonna have
people around you telling you that
you're crazy that you're stupid that you
have a vision of the world that doesn't
yet exist and you're gonna grow and be
the one that created and most people
can't see it because it's not logical
because you're leading with your heart
and not your head and so it's hard for
people to understand that and they're
gonna be critical a lot of people gonna
be jealous of you too right you're off
doing this crazy thing and you're off
living your jeans well they're stuck in
some dead-end job that they don't want
to be part of so you're gonna get lots
of criticism put on you and to keep
going you have to have confidence that
it's gonna work out and it's really
tough at the start as an entrepreneur
because you're gonna make mistakes
because you don't know what you're doing
because you know you don't have it all
worked out there are tons of holes in
your business plan but you go forward
anyway and you have confidence that it's
going to work out and that you'll you'll
find their staircase as you start to
walk that's part of being an
entrepreneur you know by the time you
have all the information it's too late
to seize an opportunity so you have to
get going and start even though you
don't quite know how you're gonna get
there you know the why but you don't
know the how yet and for those of you
who don't have the high level of
confidence it's not something that just
happens overnight it's not just some
confidence switch that you can turn on
confidence comes through a series of
actions where you're pushing yourself
right so the opposite of confidence if
you're nervous or if you're scared and
you don't take action right you you
shrink down instead of rise up to the
occasion and so anytime that you feel
yourself shrinking down and being afraid
and being scared and not doing the thing
that you feel like you should do but you
don't do it every time you were in that
situation you say yes you build more
confidence if you could take some big
project that looks super big and super
scary you break it down to the smallest
component and just do that then you can
get to the next step and you can get to
the next step you can take get to the
next step and doing that again is easy
because you've done it before and so you
have the confidence to then expand the
circle every step along the way and so
it's not just something that you turn on
but get into the habit of pushing
yourself outside of your comfort zone
stretching a little bit more every
single time and soon people look at you
is this super confident person but
really all you've done is said yes and
yes and yes and yes every time you were
faced with a difficult decision so the
question today today is how are you
building your confidence leave it in the
comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of interesting
Peevy go